the european satellites mas an orbiting
data dispenser every second it records
an area of 1 million square kilometers
beaming the footage back to earth
800 kilometers below climate experts in
Hamburg are busy analyzing the data Lars
kaliesha is one of them he's a sea ice
physicist and is using the satellite
data to monitor how ice and the Arctic
is changing in September 2012 he found a
new record the ice cap was at its
smallest since satellite monitoring
began in the 1970s caleche can also draw
on extremely high-resolution satellite
images but only for one small area at a
time as eid fascinas talk to one you can
see various structures you can see open
water and then the older ice that has
survived the summer and exhibits ice
ridges nice that's the kind of thing you
can only recognize on this
high-resolution satellite image can
that's why calèche guy needs more data
he wants to be able to monitor the
entire Arctic in detail it's what
Susette Signori techno we need new
technology to be able to conduct the
necessary measurements we need new
antenna systems we need new satellites
that can provide us with high-resolution
images over the entire area flesh and
ekend in who are all frozen constantly
fun the data that's still missing can be
extrapolated by climate researchers for
that they make use of so-called grid
cells that can extend up into the
atmosphere or into the depths of the
ocean variables such as temperature or
pressure are determined for each cell
applying this method meteorologists
jinsong von storch has taken on the
world's oceans she uses systems of
equations that describe the movements in
the ocean science salt content
temperature and the speed and direction
of currents they all adhere to certain
laws and those laws provide the basic
equations for our model human she owns a
motel
this model could never be calculated by
the human brain it requires a
supercomputer like blizzard at the
German climate computing center Blizzard
carries out over 150 trillion
calculations per second Javon yoga
practice tough luck this is basically
the laboratory where the climate
researchers can do their experiments we
have a lot of different computers here
which are all linked together on an
extremely high powered network so that
they can all work together on a problem
the supercomputer has produced something
that is so far unique in climate
research a detailed model of the ocean
with a resolution of 10 kilometers per
pixel complete with water temperature
currents and vortices right down to the
very bottom of the sea the tivo odeon
the deeper ocean is the big mystery we
don't know enough about it there are
hardly any observations available but
this model provides us with an initial
insight into how it looks an ocean of
calculated data it's another step on the
road to mapping out the Earth's entire
complex climate system on the computer